martina was two months old when we came
here to mit
it's a great experience to the whole
family i got a great support from the
whole community from all the other
partners from the beginning
at first it seems like it would be a big
deal to just uproot and go somewhere
else for a year
but we talked about it and we realized
that if we're in boston that's a whole
new experience for our children and for
us
and when we go back
we're all the better for it
finding where the best public schools
for our kids would be
was the first starter and then we built
our life around that
we live in brookline it's
right across the river from mit
it's a beautiful walk for a little over
a mile along the river basin
it's a nice way to start the morning
before class
the program impresses your family it
impresses the partners it embraces the
kids
the brazilian organized this really nice
brazilian party
whenever we get together
it's like seeing old friends and family
again and we just jump back in and start
talking about catching up on everything
it's like we've known each other for
years and years it's really a beautiful
wonderful community
and it was a chance for my wife to take
a break from the work that she does and
to spend more time with our kids
although i'm not technically working in
the medical field this year because
we're in boston there are so many
medical conferences that occur in the
city i've had a wonderful opportunity to
take advantage of those martina
i now know everyone's children i know
the ages of their children we've had
multiple babies born this year we've had
four engagements and you go to the next
event and those little babies now
walking you know so you start
participating in people's lives
one of the greatest things that i would
take from this is just the friendship
that i have built here i mean i just
feel like going and visiting everyone in
the next couple of years we wouldn't
stop traveling for the next 10 years
for our whole family it's been really an
amazing experience
you